Speaker 1: I am going to play for you now
clips from the most humiliating, deranged
and disastrous interview that I can ever remember
Donald Trump giving since the start of his
political career.
Trump seems visibly scared in this interview.
This interview took place last night on Fox
News with Sean HANNITY after the news that
New York was suing Trump and his family for
250 million and seeking to prevent him from
doing any business in New York.
After Trump's own special master said, You
got to cut the crap because these explanations
aren't cutting it.
And after a judge determined that, yes, the
Department of Justice can now resume its investigation
of Trump with the documents they seized at
Mar a Lago, Trump is scared, and when Trump
gets scared, he becomes belligerent, belligerent
without even drinking.
Let's get right into this.
Trump missing from Fox News for a while, allowed
back on and before we even get into the criminal
stuff.
Trump continuing this impossible to understand
statement that he both completed the wall
and was just about to finish it when he left
office.
Speaker 2: Everlong And they just dismantled
that.
They wouldn't finish the wall.
The wall was completed.
The original section was completed.
Said, Let's do more.
We did more.
He could have had that finished in three weeks.
Speaker 1: Okay.
The wall was done.
But then they stopped it.
But we had completed it.
And then they said we could do it in three
weeks.
I can't even make sense of that, so I'm not
even going to try.
Let's just continue.
Here is Donald Trump addressing this issue
of the values of his properties.
See if you can make sense of this.
Speaker 2: And she said we're going to get
him that.
Her whole campaign was based on that.
And then she came after us.
We've been going over this for years.
And I actually thought because our values
are really high, the company is great.
I built a great company like places like this,
so many other places that I have like this,
frankly, I mean, just to do among the finest
places.
Speaker 1: And we can't even address the substance.
Just he gets locked into this.
My places are great in the world.
Speaker 2: I actually thought that they would
never bring a case and she brought it.
And the reason I thought because she didn't
have a case, I was of the impression she wanted
to settle, but I had a problem because how
do you pay something, even if it's a small
amount of money if you're not guilty?
Speaker 1: This was he thought she was going
to.
I mean, it's completely unintelligible, folks.
I thought we were just going to settle with
her instead.
But also, how do you do guilty when you didn't
do anything wrong?
But why were you expecting to settle then?
What are you talking about?
It doesn't make any sense.
This continues to just get worse and worse.
Trump, unable to answer any question directly
asked by Sean HANNITY Were you actually the
one filling out the loan applications?
I don't think Trump even answers that question.
Speaker 2: Go back to Letitia James.
Did you ever in.
Speaker 3: Your life fill out a loan application
when in the Trump Organization?
Speaker 2: Well, you know, we make loans,
but I have very little debt.
Speaker 1: The question was, do you fill out
the application?
Speaker 2: Here's what I want to tell you
what make.
I might add one thing.
They've demeaned me for years with this stuff,
and now they find out I have very little debt.
Speaker 1: He doesn't answer the question.
Okay.
The question was, do you fill out the loan
apps?
And Trump goes, I don't have much debt and
you know, we make loans, but who knows?
Here.
HANNITY actually seems to try to help Trump
come up with possible legal defenses.
They're not great ideas, I have to tell you.
Speaker 3: I was told that in your financial
statements, when you make a loan application
and you can confirm or.
Speaker 2: If you know or not know this.
Do you put in a caveat that actually says
these are valuations because I don't know,
lending institution.
Speaker 3: A bank, a financial institution
that would lend money to anybody.
Speaker 2: And just go by the borrower's estimation
of valuation of a particular property.
Speaker 3: So if you're buying a $100 million
property and you're.
Speaker 2: Putting X, Y and Z up for leverage,
you estimate its value.
And this they estimated at this.
Don't they have a fiduciary responsibility
before you?
They give you that amount of money so that
they determine what the value is.
First of all, these are banks that have the
best law firms in the world, the biggest and
best and most powerful.
They do their own work.
They don't rely on us.
But what they do is we have a disclaimer and
we put so.
Speaker 1: Understand the subterfuge whether
or not not that is true.
And it is true, generally speaking, that that's
that banks do that.
It doesn't make it any less fraudulent for
Trump to put a bunch of this stuff on paper
in the way that he did, as outlined in the
200 page lawsuit.
Speaker 2: As my people put it together, I
would look at it and it looked fine, but it's
not overly important.
What's important is the property of the best
property.
What happened, Sean, is we have a disclaimer
right on the front and it basically says,
you know, get your own people, you're at your
own risk.
This was done by management.
It wasn't done by a it was done by management.
So don't rely on the statement that you're
getting.
And it's and by the way, it goes on for like
a page and a half.
It's a very big disclaimer.
It's a very powerful disclaimer.
Speaker 1: Super powerful guys.
It's nobody's ever seen a disclaimer this
powerful to be to be completely honest.
Trump then continues to argue he he's almost
continuing to argue the false real estate
values that are at the crux of the lawsuit.
He just keeps saying these are the values
after saying, well, it's subjective.
So even if it's worth less, it's not really
my problem.
Now, he says, Well, these are the values.
Speaker 2: And ability to come up with their
own valuation because they've got their own
bosses and shareholders that they have to
answer to.
So they would look at a property like this.
I don't even have a mortgage on this property.
I don't have a mortgage on most of my properties.
Speaker 1: Okay.
I actually I want to address that for a second.
You and I might say you either have a mortgage
on a property or you own it outright in these
big commercial properties, hotels and resorts
and this type of thing, saying I don't have
a mortgage versus I don't have debt are two
different things.
Because in these types of properties, sometimes
they are financed with debt to equity financing.
It's not a mortgage.
A mortgage is not the instrument.
Sometimes you would have a commercial loan.
Sometimes it's a commercial construction loan
because you're buying a property for 50 million
and another 25 million for work.
And so you need 75 million and you put down
10%.
It's not a mortgage, strictly speaking.
They're not mortgages, but it is still debt.
And so that all of these little statements
are misdirection at their core.
Speaker 2: You know, I used to read where
he's overextended and he had so much money
borrowed.
And I'm saying, what are they talking about?
But and actually, the one good thing is people
see what a great company I built.
I built a great company.
A powerful company.
Speaker 1: You're getting sued for lying.
And he's talking about his company.
Speaker 2: A company that's very lonely, leveraged
with among the best assets anywhere in the
world.
I mean, you look at this and said she has
this down to $75 billion.
I can tell you it's many times that number.
She said, oh, he evaluated at 75 or whatever
it is or she valued at 75.
Speaker 1: He doesn't even know what he's
saying.
This is, by the way, Mar-A-Lago.
What they're talking about is Mar a Lago,
which Letitia James believes is worth 75 million,
and Trump believes his worth worth 739 million.
Speaker 2: Letitia James No, but if I were
going, I don't have a mortgage on this property.
If I was going to put a mortgage on this property,
the institutions are going to be coming over.
They're going to go through comparable properties
all over Palm Beach or whatever it is, wherever
it may be.
Miami, we have them all over.
We have tremendous properties.
Speaker 1: So he's completely all over the
place.
Then it starts to get almost a little bit
sad where Trump admits he has trouble referring
himself to himself as a former president.
Speaker 2: When they're here, we could do
lots of things.
We I think we had good security.
We had as you know, we had tremendous Secret
Service.
They are unbelievable people.
And they're all over Mar a Lago, as happens
to a former president, etc., etc..
I hate to use the word former because I have
a lot of problems with what happened, but
the fact is we wouldn't be having all these
problems that we have right now, by the way,
with Ukraine and Russia talking about.
Speaker 1: This has nothing to do with Ukraine
and Russia.
Speaker 2: Your weapons.
Now, I want to get to all of that, because
what's happening in the world is horrible.
Speaker 1: It's a horrible thing what's happening
in the world.
At another point during the interview, Trump
again went back to the FBI, planted evidence
at Mar a Lago.
Now, that is old ground, which I thought he
had gotten away from by saying they didn't
plant it.
It was totally fine for me to have it.
But I guess we're going back to maybe it was
planted.
Speaker 2: When Hillary broke them up, broke
up all our phones with the hammers and they
did the bleach because.
Speaker 1: Now this story is Hillary with
a hammer smashing up Trump's iPhone.
Speaker 2: Well, the things that happened
were incredible.
Well, you could also say 33 million documents
or pages with President Obama.
That's very questionable.
33 million.
3000.
Happens to be a similar number, 33 million.
Speaker 1: That's suspicious, guys.
33.
A lot of 33 going on.
Speaker 2: They're fighting over them or arguing
over them.
The problem that you have is they go into
rooms they won't let anybody near.
They wouldn't even let them in the same building.
Did they drop anything into those piles?
Speaker 1: There it is.
There is the suggestion the FBI could have
dropped any of that stuff, which I, by the
way, declassified.
Why would you declassify the very things the
FBI is planning to leave there?
Then maybe the wacky the second wackiest moment
of this interview, Trump says he can declassified
documents telepathically.
By thinking about it, folks.
Speaker 2: Please stand it.
You know, there's different people say different
things.
But as I said, that doesn't have to be if
you're the president of the United States,
you can declassify just by saying it's declassified,
even by thinking about it.
Right.
Because you're sending it to Mar a Lago or
to wherever you're sending it.
And there doesn't have to be a process.
There can be a process, but it doesn't have
to be.
Speaker 1: So Trump can telepathically declassify
documents, but he didn't take them.
They might have been planted by the FBI.
And it just so happened that they had been
telepathically declassified by Donald Trump.
Here is the final moment from this interview
and it is so unintelligible.
Trump is on a word salad that is so unintelligible
that about a minute in HANNITY tries to stop
Trump to help him, because what he's saying
is making so little sense.
And even HANNITY can't save Trump.
Speaker 2: So let me ask you this question,
because I think this is the next logical question,
because the president of the United States,
you, unlike, say, Hillary Clinton, in her
case, a president has the power to declassify.
Right.
Okay.
You said untruth, social a number of times.
You declined to declassify.
Is there a process?
What was your process to do?
Does it have to be a process, as I understand
it?
You know, there's different people say different
things, but as I understand, it doesn't have
to be if you're the president of the United
States, you can declassify just by saying
it's declassified, even by thinking about
it because you're sending it to Mar a Lago
or to wherever you're sending it.
And it doesn't have to be a process.
There can be a process, but it doesn't have
to be.
Speaker 1: All right.
So that's what we saw before.
And now it goes off the rails.
And within 30 seconds, HANNITY tries to help
and even he can't save Trump.
Speaker 2: Is it you make that decision.
So when you send it, it's declassified.
We I declassified everything.
No, I declassified things.
And we were having a lot of problems with
Mary.
You know, Neera is a radical left group of
people running that thing.
And when you send documents over there, I
would say there's a very good chance that
a lot of those documents will never be seen
again.
There's also a lot of speculation because
of what they did, the severity of the FBI
becomes HANNITY raiding Mar-A-Lago.
Were they looking for the Hillary Clinton
emails that were deleted?
But they are around someplace.
Were they looking for the final say?
You had it?
No, no.
They may be saying they may have thought that
it wasn't okay.
And a lot of people said the only thing is.
Speaker 1: Trump saying the FBI might have
thought Hillary's bleached e-mails were at
Mar a Lago.
I can't tell you what he's saying.
Speaker 2: Would if the kind of severity that
they showed by actually coming in and rating
with many, many people.
Is the Hillary Clinton deal, the Russia, Russia,
Russia stuff or.
I mean, there there are a number of things,
the spying on Trump's campaign center.
Speaker 1: Folks.
This guy is scared in a way.
I've never seen him be scared.
I think that's the explanation here.
The behavior, the delusions, the unhinged
nature.
There is something materially different here.
And I believe it's that Trump is scared out
of his wits.
Let me know.
We will have this clip on our Facebook page.
We will have it on our Instagram.
I want to hear from you.
All right.
Let's cover a couple
of other things.